there's been a political shake-up across
the pond the unlikely candidate and left
winger Jeremy Corbyn was just elected as
leader of the British Labour Party the
main government opposition but I'm an
American why should I care well it turns
out Corbin's beliefs are really left and
he embodies the anti corporate anti-war
tax the rich Pro economic and quality
ideals that so many are looking for
which sounds a bit like someone I know
oh hello Bernie as it turns out these
two have a lot in common
they both represented the left in
politics for a long time have attracted
huge crowds in recent rallies motivated
young people and terrified their party's
more mainstream members oh and they both
have trademark hair the magnitude of
Corbin's win wasn't lost on the Vermont
senator either Sanders told The
Huffington Post he was delighted to see
Corbin win the Labour Party vote he said
we need leadership in every country in
the world which tells the billionaire
class that they cannot have it all so
what role does corbin actually have now
over there in London well as an
opposition leader he can set the policy
agenda to challenge the Prime Minister
and the leading party the opposition
leader also creates what are called
shadow cabinet members people who speak
for the party on all sorts of issues so
far a majority of Corbin Shadow
appointments have been women and he's
established a minister for mental health
something that's never existed before
so you could say Corbin is already
making a statement both Sanders and
Corbin were said to have hard
any chance of winning thanks to the
resistance from their respective parties
back in July even Tony Blair former
labor prime minister told those whose
hearts were swayed by Corbin to quote
get a transplant you first Tony Corbin
may have beaten the odds this time but
there's already speculation that he's
too much of a lefty to become Prime
Minister Prime Minister David Cameron is
already sounding the alarm he tweeted
that the Labour Party is now a threat to
our national security and some
democratic strategists are worried that
Sanders wouldn't be moderate enough to
capture the general election either so
if a win from a populist lefty bearded
politician could happen across the pond
could it happen here
you